et pour tout le monde sofiane tout va
bien et tu es heureux oui bon jusqu'à ya
twitter tu m'as dit que tu avais un rêve
c'était peut-être de rencontrer
quelqu'un de télé réalité alors j'ai
réfléchi j'ai dit qui je pourrais lui
faire rencontrer et j'ai une surprise
pour toi
[Musique]
pas trop pressé les bienvenus à côté de
moi parce que tu es content tu es
content mon chalet reprises il m'a
appelé il ya une demi heure je suis allé
mais des prix taxi fait tout paris de
niro pacino des princes
je suis très content que mon fils soit
la cause et marester tu veux pas le voir
après après l'émission il m'a parlé toi
sinon il m'a dit voilà j'ai rencontré un
jeune gac bouleversant attachant et m'a
dit je vais le suivre
je vais l'aider donc tu vois il est là
voilà un proche parent avec toi comme ça
il va t'attendre il t'attend dans sa
loge à la pression est là et encore une
fois pas l'ensemble tous les cantons se
fier à des rennais mais tous sont émus
quand même
mais oui parce que je sais qu'ils voient
là c'est son truc c'est son âge il
ils adorent ça et je trouve ça super
gentil de la part de votre fils d'un
d'avoir fait la démarche de venir même
si pourtant souvent qu'un joli numéro ce
que je fais c'est pas grande chose est
aussi parce que pour d'autres ça paraît
pas grand chose mais ils ne le font pas
ce qu'il a fait lui a fait la différence
j'aime pas ce que parce qu'il est
heureux en tout cas du côté de ce que je
peux te dire c'est mon fils il a un
coeur gros comme ça comme son père